bonjour jean marc allaire d'abord
expliqué locales et à quel est l'état
des lieux
écoutez c'est très simple actuellement
les cinq plus grandes compagnies
pétrolières du monde sont quasiment à
genoux à terre pendant le seul deuxième
trimestre de l'année on vient d'avoir
les chiffres
elles ont enregistré au total plus de 45
milliards d'euros en pertes
alors qu'en temps normal elle accumule
bien sûr des profits considérables les
plus grandes compagnies la british
petroleum britannique le chevron exxon
qui sont les deux grandes américaines
sont complètement étrangler et puis
derrière ce tiercé mais à vous avez
aussi la chaîne hollandaise totale
française qui elles aussi ont fait des
parcours désastre total par exemple
c'est plus d'un milliard de pertes alors
il ya plusieurs raisons à tout ça bien
sûr il ya l'arrêt de la consommation
vous le disiez consommation de pétrole
pendant la période de confinement c'est
pas d'épidémie elle même si le
confinement finalement qui a abîmé
beaucoup ces entreprises il ya plus
d'avis avait plus d'avion plus
déplacements en voiture presque pas du
sinn
la demande s'est complètement effondré
donc les prix se sont effondrés
et puis parallèlement on a eu cette
guerre des prix cette concurrence entre
la russie et l'arabie saoudite qui a qui
a augmenté la production globale et qui
a elle aussi participé à la chute des
prix alors les prix sont tombés partout
en dessous de 16 dollars le baril y
compris aux états unis qui auront aussi
une énorme capacité de production avec
les gaz de schiste qui avait été relancé
par donald on a donc vu les prix
s'effondrer aux états unis et même des
prix négatifs
c'est incroyable mais on a vu des
producteurs de pétrole qui paient pour
qu'on leur prenne leurs stocks qui nous
subit qui suppliaient les consommateurs
ne prendre les stocks parce qu'ils
savaient pas quoi en faire
c'est assez incroyable cette situation
et cet essai historique de déconfinement
et la reprise de l'activité normale
vara mais cette industrie avec libre bah
écoutez normalement n'avait pas
forcément tort depuis le début du mois
de juin les cours de pétrole ont
augmenté à 40 dollars le baril mais le
dollar a beaucoup baissé
alors donc l'industrie est loin d'avoir
retrouvé ces seuils de rentabilité
aujourd'hui il ya un an ou deux vous
savez on avait encore des prix du
pétrole à plus de 70 80 dollars le baril
avec un dollar qui était lui même
beaucoup plus cher aujourd'hui donc on
est loin on est très loin de l'équilibré
vous avez des pans entiers du secteur
qui sont des valeurs
zé démonétisé ils sont peut-être
dévaloriser définitivement pourquoi gars
parce que cette crise a sans doute
accélérer la mutation énergétique la
prise de conscience on va sans doute
vivre autrement consommer de moins en
moins de pétrole tous les experts
parient sur un développement des
énergies alternatives
alors les grandes compagnies à elle même
si près par un total est devenu un gros
producteur d'électricité d'origine
naturelle des éoliennes notamment mais
pour assurer cette mutation
il faut beaucoup investir il faut de
l'argent et on comptait beaucoup sur
l'argent du pétrole les pays producteurs
eux mêmes sont également très perturbé
leurs revenus pétroliers se sont
écroulés et ils n'ont pas pu se sont pas
préparés au changement en trouvant des
modèles de développement différent les
pays du golfe par exemple les émirats
l'arabie saoudite vont avoir du mal à
négocier ce virage ce qu'ils en créent
des problèmes à la fois politiques et
sociaux en interne d'autres sont plus
avancées la russie qui est un gros
producteur de gaz par ailleurs est un
peu à l'abri le canada a également mené
l'algérie par exemple c'est pas beaucoup
préparer au changement le seul pays qui
ne semble pas prendre cette mutation
énergétique au sérieux à long terme
c'est l'amérique de donald trump qui a
acquis sur un dépendance pétrolière
c'est vrai en relançant l'exploitation
des gaz de schiste mais les acteurs du
système même savent bien que cette
ambition de trump n'est pas rentable
trump ne crois pas aux énergies
renouvelables
il ne croit pas au réchauffement
climatique alors que la plupart des
industriels américains savent que elles
ne vont pas devenir l banque devenir
compétitive assez rapidement ces
énergies alternatives donc finalement
elles prendront la place
mécaniquement du pétrole et alors pour
l'automobiliste est ce que c'était
pourtant une bonne nouvelle ah oui alors
ça c'est paradoxal d'automobilistes qui
roulent tous les jours oui c'est une
bonne nouvelle n'a jamais payé l'essence
ou le diesel aussi peu cher
il se plaint pas actuellement c'est vrai
qu'ils ne se plaint pas mais pour celui
qui s'inquiètent en même temps de
l'environnement du réchauffement
climatique va ça devrait être une très
mauvaise nouvelle
le pétrole pas cher n'aide pas la
protection de l'environnement ils
n'aident pas les investissements
alternatifs
les militants écologistes qui rêvent de
voitures électriques mais ils n'achètent
pas pourquoi parce que c'est encore trop
cher si tu entends trop compliqué pour
voyager il ya quand même des problèmes
d'autonomie
et paradoxalement écouter sida c'est
curieux c'est que ceux qui sont le plus
en avance dans la transition énergétique
ce sont les industriels du pétrole qui
sont les premiers touchés les total et
les autres
les grandes compagnies elles veulent
développer les alternatives et mettre
les moyens pour ça cet édito de jean
marc sylvestre merci beaucoup
selon marca plus tard